in the new book lyndon johnson in europe
thomas allen schwartz considers LBJ's
foreign policy in the context of the
Cold War this talk runs about 50 minutes
thank you for joining the alley us to
celebrate bastille day and to celebrate
the history of franco-american relations
the elegance one says is pleased to
present this another cultural and
educational events and soirees
throughout the year from casual
conversation groups at our resource
center at green hills to literary groups
and festive soirees the youngest one
says the Nashville makes possible a wide
variety of interesting activities and
events for its 300 members and strives
to reach out to the community to foster
stronger international relations and
understanding in the past we've learned
with Amy who spoke to us about 19th
century French art and tonight we have
pleasure of hearing from her husband on
behalf of the alliance française de
Nashville it is my pleasure to welcome
dr. Thomas Schwartz who teaches the
history of American foreign relations at
Vanderbilt University
I want to take one moment just to thank
the University Club for its very
hospitable and generous treatment of
this event which went well beyond sort
of core collegial politeness to the
organization I also want to thank
Allianz francaise for inviting me here
to speak tonight it's not often that a
historians work coincides with current
concerns and so I appreciate the
opportunity to address this group
tonight I'm going to call my talk the
United States and France historical
perspectives contemporary challenges the
headlines proclaimed NATO crisis worsens
and Atlantic Alliance and disarray the
French government bitterly criticised
American policy refusing to support the
American military buildup German
newspapers Lampoon the American defense
secretary for his harsh language about
their responsibility as allies of the
United States many Americans called for
the withdrawal of American troops from
Europe public protests erupted in
European cities and the president from
Texas was criticized for his cowboy
style of diplomacy and his preference
for using unilateral military force
against third world nations sound
familiar although these issues resemble
today's news they actually are taken
from my research from my book and
described the NATO crisis of 1966 I'm 37
years ago when President Lyndon Baines
Johnson faced the imperious French
leader Charles de Gaulle you put the
first one on thanks
this cartoon I'm using some political
cartoons partly the influence of my wife
would just finished a book on political
cartoons but i'm using ones that i
couldn't get the rights for to use in my
book but this one of charles de gaulle
and johnson I think sort of captures
some of the contemporary setting and
saying we have a saying among historians
most people outside of our profession
often quote the words of George
Santayana that those who don't remember
the past are condemned to repeat it
those of us who are historians who do
recognize the problem of finding useable
lessons in the past are fond of a
slightly different saying which cloak
Willie would go something like history
doesn't repeat itself but it sure rhymes
a lot in this case and largely because
I've written a book on the subject I'd
like to talk about one of those rhymes
to our contemporary situation and it's
very ironic since my book was coming out
really at the time of the recent US
French crisis over Iraq for a moment
though let me take you back almost 40
years to the crisis between our first
Texas president and the famous French
leader very much the spiritual godfather
of jacques chirac charles de gaulle the
gall of course known i'm sure familiar
to all of you the wartime leader of the
free french at the time he was the last
Western leader to harken back to World
War two in 1966 churchill stalin
Roosevelt all of them were gone by that
time he was determined to challenge
American leadership within the Alliance
and in March 1966 he announced that
France would withdraw its forces from
the military structure of NATO and that
he would soon travel to Moscow to know
denote negotiate with the new leaders of
the Kremlin denouncing American policy
in Vietnam and everywhere else de Gaulle
styled himself the independent champion
of a Europe that would stretch that
could now stand on its own two feet and
it would stretch from the Atlantic to
the Urals the French leader hoped to
build a foundation on the 1963
franco-german treaty and pull the young
West German Republic away from its
dependency on Washington he believed
that the cold war in Europe was
essentially over and the general is he
was always referred to was a man in a
hurry
determined to achieve french grand or
within Europe Lyndon Johnson in de
gaulle's view was a vulgar Texan and a
mediocre politician and it was as he
told his friend Konrad Adenauer the
German Chancellor absolutely intolerable
that Europe was dependent upon the
United States and the man he called it's
accidental president accidental was de
Gaulle's reference of course to the
circumstances surrounding Johnson's rise
to power in particular of course the
assassination President Kennedy which de
Gaulle always suspected of course had
something to do with the fact that it
was in Texas and this sort of thing on a
personal level of course Kennedy had
been very popular in France his wife
spoke French and to the French sanity
Kennedy seemed cosmopolitan and European
his death came as an immense shock and
elevated him to something like a martyr
like status within France this despite
the fact that policy differences between
the two governments were very similar to
the ones Johnson would face and in fact
only a month before the death of Kennedy
a poll in France found that a majority
had little confidence in him as a
Western leader de Gaulle not only
challenged American political leadership
in 1966 but he also went after Americans
at a very sensitive point namely their
money de Gaulle directly challenged the
so-called Bretton Woods system which had
stabilized international finance and
trade after World War 2 by making the
American dollar worth a fixed amount of
gold this is a complex subject I'd be
glad to go into detail in questions but
I raised it because it gave us
significance to the French challenge in
the 1960s that is not sufficiently
appreciated the united states after
world war two lengths the value of the
dollar to gold guaranteeing that it
would redeem all dollars with gold and
subsequently all currencies adjusted
their value accordingly however by the
1960s with the economic recovery of
Europe and Japan the special position of
the dollar seemed unwarranted and for
his part de Gaulle believed that the
system afforded the United States an
unfair advantage in maintaining what he
saw as its hegemony over Europe allowing
it to pay for an expensive military
establishment it's war in Vietnam and
it's increasing social programs under
Johnson's Great Society
traditionalist that he was the gall
advocator to return to the gold standard
whereby all currencies would have a
fixed value in gold and begin and he
himself also began redeeming the dollars
that France had earned in foreign
exchange with gold from the United
States in the content of that in the
context of the time this was a bit like
a run on the bank as if every nation did
what France was doing the United States
would not be able to meet its
obligations he put up the second this
was captured in a political cartoon of
the time which is one of my my favorites
gall finger as you see he's got his
finger directed toward Fort Knox and the
film Goldfinger had just come out around
this time and the Washington Post
columnist herb block used this as his
motif for de Gaulle's raid on the
American Treasury this was a dangerous
tactic as one which the American
Treasury Department termed in a secret
memorandum that I was able to get
Declassified as economic warfare and
they saw it as a context of a national
policy that was designed to weaken
American strength and power in Europe as
a necessary condition to establishing
French control and the Treasury
Department actually wanted to take
covert action against the French economy
during this time which was was vetoed by
obj but they were quite serious about
what they saw as the threat posed the
confrontation between the United States
and France during this time was further
exacerbated by the stinging French
denunciation of america's intervention
in vietnam looking back from our
perspective now of course we know that
many of the french criticisms of
american policy were sadly very correct
the French had learned their own
experience in Indochina and as de Gaulle
told one American diplomat Vietnam was a
rotten country and attempts by outsiders
to direct the country were doomed to
failure at the time however American
fears of communist expansion were such
that the country was not prepared to
accept such advice and the fact that
French criticism was encased within a
larger set of anti-american
pronouncements weakened its impact since
it seemed as the next cartoon i have
would suggest that the gall simply said
no when the united states proposed
this is another one I don't think you
can see it it's Johnson with de Gaulle
there's a little bit of a caption at the
bottom actually that reads or at the top
maybe that reads de Gaulle stone and
this had to do of course with the fact
that those of you old enough of course
remember that Johnson had a gallbladder
operation during the time he was in
office the the reference of course to de
Gaulle's opposition to all of his
policies some of you may remember a more
famous aspect and maybe we can aim if
you have the next cartoon another aspect
was that Johnson showed people his scar
this was made into a cartoon which I
think also captured issues those of you
who also may remember it's Johnson
points to his scar that the shape of the
outline of South Vietnam this was a
cartoon done by David Levine in new york
review of books at the time this also
this cartoon actually reflects why I
subtitled my book in the shadow of
Vietnam for Vietnam has cast its shadow
over almost all aspects of Johnson's
foreign policy historians rarely credit
Lyndon Johnson with any skills in the
conduct of foreign policy to most
scholars at pundits Johnson was the
classic Ugly American or has one put it
the quintessential provincial who was
ill-equipped by nature and temperament
to deal with foreign policy compared
with both his predecessor the
cosmopolitan and urbane John Kennedy and
his successor the sinister but geo
politically astute Richard Nixon Johnson
comes off especially in the foreign
policy realm as one writer put it the
last of the really big Hicks and we
could put up the next one it was also an
element and I confess that this point
has come to me probably from living in
Nashville for the last 13 years this is
a cartoon her block did comparing
Johnson to a slave owner there was an
element of derision toward Johnson as a
southerner and as a as a hick during his
time even with his achievements and
what's ironic about this cartoon coming
as it does is of course Johnson's great
civil rights achievement didn't immune
immunize him from the stereotype of a
domineering southern slave master as
was done at the time Johnson sometimes
played to this image of a hick
especially on foreign policy matters he
once told the reporters on on his plane
boys I don't understand foreigners
they're different from US diplomatic
professionals love telling stories of
Johnson's travels during and especially
his excesses during trips abroad one
story for example that was told me by a
diplomat about Johnson's travels to
Germany Johnson always demanded a very
high-pressure shower be installed for
his use when he traveled and they had to
install this in the ancient u.s. embassy
and bond and the result was to rupture
all the pipes and flood the building
another story told of from the same trip
was of a presidential advance man one of
the many legions of people who travel
with the president's was scouting out
the bedroom that the president was going
to be staying and and noticed there were
large number of bookcases there and he
immediately told the Ambassador get rid
of those bookcases the president doesn't
like books this type of thing was told
frequently and I think such personal
foibles might have been excused in such
a colorful colorful figure as LBJ except
the failure of America's war in Vietnam
casts a very long shadow historians will
credit Johnson with his achievements in
domestic legislation if they always
balance this against his disastrous
course in Southeast Asia and they see
this as the overall failure of his
foreign policy what I've tried to do in
my book is actually though argue for
more balance in the assessment and one
of the things I argue for in this is
Johnson's handling of de Gaulle in the
NATO crisis of 1966 Johnson could have
used the crisis in 1966 for domestic
political gain rallying Americans behind
his Vietnam policy by denouncing the
ungrateful French even as fierce a
critic of lb of LBJ is the head of the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee at
the time J William Fulbright found de
gaulle's approach to diplomacy offensive
the political cartoonist bill mauldin to
a caricature of de Gaulle standing among
the white crosses in the cemetery at
Normandy
and this one I chose to show you just
because of course it has two parallels
as you see de Gaulle among the white
crosses saying why do you Americans stay
where you're not wanted the reason I put
this up in many as those of you know
very recently the New York Post during
the crisis in March published a picture
of an American Cemetery in France with
the caption they died for france but now
France has forgotten and one congressman
actually proposed repatriating American
graves from France that was an emotional
issue and if the administration in the
1960s had chosen to use it it could have
tapped into a sentiment that we saw this
current administration actually do a
sort of emotional unthinking response to
issues of International Affairs Johnson
did not respond this way he scooped he
scrupulously observed a somewhat folksy
dictum that he had given to his
secretary of defense robert mcnamara as
he put it when a man asks you to leave
his house you don't argue you get your
hat and go and in fact johnson directed
his advisers to expedite the withdrawal
of nato headquarters from paris and all
american soldiers from france he refused
to get into a public argument with de
gaulle and he reigned in his anti de
gaulle advisors many of whom were the
most sophisticated US diplomats of the
day later termed the wise men people
like Dean Acheson george ball John
McCloy these establishment leaders were
convinced that the United States should
somehow punish France under article 5 of
the NATO treaty and withdraw its
security guarantee interestingly enough
many of them believed that such an
action would lead the French public to
turn against de Gaulle a surprisingly
misguided view a French opinion at the
time Johnson may have been provincial
but he understood geography as long as
the United States was defending West
Germany would also be defending France
no matter what the French did or said to
publicly provoke Washington I think this
is one of those areas in which I see a
sharp contrast with the most recent
crisis I think the present
administration saw it in its political
interest
build support for its war by driving up
sentiment against the French in
particular the actions of republican
congressional figures like the house
leader dennis hastert and media outlets
close to the administration like fox
news some of this was spontaneous some
of the attitude but i suspect the very
strong political motivation as well the
advisors also at the time wanted Johnson
to force the Germans to kick French
troops out of Germany French troops had
been stationed in germany since the end
of World War two and they had actually
become a symbol of the reconciliation
that had taken place between Germany and
France after the war in fact there's a
story that I tell in my book which is
one of those interesting stories that
you get from the observers of the time
and this would particularly for one of
Johnson's deputies a basically an
attempt to do an end run around the
president by insisting that the Germans
take a much tougher line against the
French in their negotiations and putting
it in the context of if you don't do
this we are you're going to suffer
consequences with us well once again
when Johnson was informed of this he
vetoed his advisors approach arguing
that the any type of blackmail American
blackmail against Germany would damage
what had been a very important goal of
the united states after world war two
namely bringing france and germany
together again after their two
horrendously bloody wars or three i
should say three horrendously bloody
wars over the last hundred years in that
sense johnson i think took a more
long-sighted view of America's role in
Europe then his advisers Johnson's
restraint which is a quality he's rarely
credited with paid off in this first
NATO crisis Johnson believe that
publicly attacking the French and the
Europeans in general would damage the
Alliance's support within the United
States and he recognized that America
strong relationship with Europe was
central to dealing with the Cold War in
the Soviet Union and fostering a stable
relationship with that nuclear rival
despite the disagree
that existed between the united states
and its European allies over Vietnam and
remember that although some of the
allies offered tepid sort of public
support none contributed troops Johnson
worked carefully with the British and
the Germans to reconstitute the
foundations of the NATO alliance for
example they moved it during that time
to Brussels in Belgium and they
reconstituted its financial burdens and
effectively isolated the French for the
time being from the rest of Europe as
something of the same also happened on
economic issues the United States was
actually able to negotiate a trade
agreement with the european economic
community as it was then known it was
called the kennedy round and tribute to
Johnson's predecessor and the United
States also broke the tight connection
between the dollar and gold during the
march 1968 gold crisis the irony was
that after the massive Paris
demonstrations in may of nineteen sixty
eight which had a terribly damaging
effect on the French economy in the
French currency it was the Johnson
administration through the International
Monetary Fund that provided the credits
to maintain the stability of the French
franc showing that in fact in
international politics it's it's always
best I think to argue with your head
than your heart Johnson also worked with
the Russians during this time to
negotiate the nuclear non-proliferation
agreement of 1968 could you put up the
law um this was designed to halt the
spread of nuclear weapons one of the
arguments in my book which runs against
some of the conventional wisdom is that
despite the Vietnam War there was
actually significant progress in
us-soviet relations during the Johnson
era largely from their mutual interest
in restraining the nuclear arms race and
limiting the availability of nuclear
weapons which in fact are really the
only significant weapon the mass
destruction out there the Johnson years
created the basis for the day Tov that's
normally associated with the nixon
europe and on nuclear non-proliferation
actually johnson found himself able to
isolate the French and the Chinese who
were the only people as you can see
opposing in their prolific way here the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty which
was negotiated and signed in July of
1968 this french opposition to the
treaty was a more isolating character
sticking actually allowed politically I
think Johnson to make progress without
being held back by the French opposition
when peace talks on Vietnam actually did
begin as some of you know they were held
in Paris the French actually offered
their services to provide them in may of
nineteen sixty eight when the Russians
invaded a liberalizing Czechoslovakia
and destroyed any hope for de gaulle's
own vision of Europe the Gauls hope that
in a sense the Russians would ease their
control of Eastern Europe and allow
Europe as a whole to come together
Johnson's policy actually allowed the
United States to resume working on a
lower level with French leaders and when
Charles de Gaulle actually did
ultimately resign his successors quietly
began cooperating with NATO again and
the NATO alliance is strength and
cohesion over the next two decades
really helped bring about the collapse
of the Soviet empire in Eastern Europe
Vietnam still casts its shadow over
Johnson's accomplishments but the war
never caused the president to lose sight
of the central importance and
significance of the Western alliance in
America's international stature that
lesson that European and American
cooperation has been vital to
international peace and stability since
World War two is one that it really
behooves us including the current
administration not to forget now there
are a couple of lessons I take from my
books analysis for what has gone on in
the last few months these may sound a
little jazzed up in political science
theory and i'll try to simply capture
them namely that in the liance of
democratic states one has to recognize
the importance of public opinion in
those states and that therefore while a
leader of the Alliance like the united
states may seek to influence that
opinion it's also important to respect
that opinion and the constraints at
places on fellow government officials
this was something Johnson never forgot
he was a politician to the core but he
never forgot the degree to which
domestic politics is utmost the
determiner of foreign policy and finally
and an issue between states even one as
significant as war
can be managed so as not to damage other
aspects of the relationship it can in
fact to use a word that I think
sometimes captures how Johnson approach
foreign policy it can be
compartmentalized separated from larger
areas of agreement and cooperation
single issues don't have to be turned
into populist issues oversimplified for
a political gain in a way of damaging a
larger and more valuable cooperation I
raised those two points because of
course this is an unusual bastille day
for those here whatever the particular
reasons behind us the fact that we're
having a dinner rather than the street
festival was deemed by some of the local
media as newsworthy this organization
which promotes goodwill between the
United States and France finds itself of
course concerned now with public
reaction to its mission any of you who
followed this and I've found myself
looking at articles on the media know
that newspaper articles of recent days
have spoken for example of an
unwillingness of American families now
to host French exchange students of
boycotts of French products all of us
know the rather infamous pujo smashing
that was carried out and the
congressional names to change products
leaving us with freedom fries and the
rest underneath all the silliness and
strangeness I think there is this is
disturbing because for whatever
differences have existed between the
united states and france there is of
course far more in common in culture
beliefs and societal values let me say a
few words about the issue as it arose of
the use of force in Iraq against Iraq
and why France opposed the United States
on this issue some of the most
frequently cited explanations which
emphasize nefarious and cowardly French
actions the type of thing that became
the staple of Jay Leno and David
Letterman's monologues I think are just
so totally misleading take for example
economic interests of France trade
between France and Iraq amounted to
perhaps two tenths
two maybe three tenths a percent of 1%
of overall French trade not a very
significant figure and in fact I think
if economic interests were the reasons
for French policy the more appropriate
strategy would have been to join the
Western coalition in a modest way and
then insist on getting its fair share of
the post-war contracts by contrast for
example French trade with the United
States the overall bilateral trade
amounts to some 47 billion a much more
significant total so economic interests
I think which were often cited as the
key to understanding French behavior
were simply wrong anti-americanism
ironically enough and from a historians
point of view this I found very
interesting at least as measured by
public opinion polls simple
anti-americanism has been declining in
French society since the 1950s and 1960s
Lyndon Johnson faced a much more raw
anti-americanism than this
administration indeed I think what's
absolutely clear from any unbiased
reading of opinion polls and public
opinion surveys is that the French were
against this war and the Bush
administration not against the United
States in general or against the against
America seventy-four percent were
against the administration only
twenty-one percent of French thought the
problem was America in at large rather
than this particular administration and
this was the third lowest rate of some
twenty countries that were surveyed
ironically enough of course Americans
tend to generalize it in see France in
general as being opposed forty-three
percent of Americans for example are
still consider it answered a survey as
less likely to buy French products
where's only seventeen percent of French
consumers expressed a reluctance to
purchase American products so I don't
think simple anti-americanism goes very
far as an explanation another often
posited explanation was the presence of
a sizable Islamic or Muslim community in
France and some argued
the presence of some 425 million Muslims
in France was a key factor in French
policy toward Iraq in fact however that
the relative size of this community is
small in voting terms in France and it
was not the key point just as it wasn't
when French president meter on joined
the coalition during the first Gulf War
or when she rocks and French forces to
fight in Afghanistan in 19 in 2001 so I
don't think that explanation holds up
the reasons that I think our strongest
for explaining or trying to understand
the French position in the recent crisis
first of all of course the weapons of
mass destruction issue the French may
have actually thought although of course
we as we all know they haven't actually
found them yet the French may have
thought along with the united states
that there were indeed weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq but their argument
is presented in diplomatic circles well
so they were far more worried about what
might happen to these weapons in the
event of an invasion and the breakdown
of Iraq into chaos then they were about
what would happen under the tightly
controlled regime of Saddam Hussein in
that sense their worries about weapons
of mass destruction which lightly we're
considerably different from that of the
United States and it seems as though in
fact as we as we know now that the case
for war made on that may have been
extremely or considerably weaker than
many thought the war on terrorism here
again one finds a very different French
perspective the French also thought that
an invasion of Iraq unless sufficiently
justified by Iraq's defiance on the
inspection regime and its defiance of
the United Nations they felt that it was
likely to fuel the recruitment of
terrorism and be a step backward in the
war on terrorism on this point one needs
to remember that in fact even within
this administration there is a ready
acknowledgement that the French have
been very cooperative in trying to fight
al-qaeda and the international terrorist
networks as they exist particularly in
the less glamorous methods of tracking
down the sources of terrorist money and
the source
behind terrorist networks the fear in
Paris was that the Iraq war would create
new terrorists who watched the United
States invade an Arab country and a
Muslim nation and would see it in terms
of that cultural conflict and would be
in that sense a recruiting element for
terrorism finally I think another factor
that explains the French attitude was a
general European pessimism and weariness
of war as a solution to political
problems I think the French and of
course I would also include the Germans
here because of their own experience
recent experience of war and their
experience as colonizers in the Arab
world don't forget that France once
ruled Syria and Lebanon are very
pessimistic about the military ability
of military power to bring democracy to
those regions the French are certainly
not pacifists witnessed their own
military actions in Africa and defensive
civilians including Americans in the
Ivory Coast and other threatened former
colonies but I think they do have a
higher threshold for choosing war as a
means to an end than the United States
showed in the Iraq war the aftermath of
the war has proven much more difficult
as all of you know than many American
officials expected we've now lost more
than 30 men in combat since the end or
since the president proclaimed the end
of major combat operations and the need
I think for internationalization and
particularly help from other countries
has become far more acute and just today
of course the country of India for
example which might have offered troops
again to help in Iraq turned down the
American request because the occupation
has not yet been sanctioned by the
United Nations at this stage I think any
outside observer an objective observer
should argue I think that it would be
best now to bury differences over the
war probably by swallowing a fair amount
of humble pie in both countries but
particularly here in the united states
where justifiable pride in the
efficiency and prowess of our military
and satisfaction at the removal of a
tyrant may blind us and i think has
blinded us to the necessity of winning
the peace
much more difficult and onerous task
than winning the war and to win the
peace in the Middle East the United
States will need far more than a tiny
Coalition of the Willing we will need to
rely again on the transatlantic Alliance
and our allies especially countries
experienced in this like France to
accomplish this objective magnum unity
and victory as well as a realization
that there was considerable truth in the
pre-war French warnings about the nature
and consequences of this war I think
could help to mend some frayed ties and
begin to focus the Western alliance on
the future French and American relations
have endured a great deal over the
course of more than two centuries of
alliance they've survived much more
bitter disputes and disagreements like
the one I talked about the beginning of
this talk but with wise leadership they
should be able to survive and prosper
into the 21st century thank you very
much
thank you again we're going to have
question and answer session for our TV
viewers we need to have you raise your
hand if you'd like to ask a question and
there be a microphone brought to you and
everyone else won't hear it won't boom
but that's for those of you in TV land
thank you do you want to recognize
people doing direct contact between
Saddam Hussein and the president of
France and that they were personal
friends and guests and all that and that
he had the French president had
financial connections in Iraq comment on
that please I think I think that was
very very overblown yes Chirac had met
with Saddam Hussein but so Donald
Rumsfeld so you have to put some of that
in context of what has been the shifting
alliances in that part of the world and
I really am often surprised my students
were very surprised when we talked about
how in the 1980s Iraq was not on a lie
but certainly a country that was
receiving us intelligence assistance in
many respects so yes there were contacts
but the argument that in some ways this
had to do with financial interests i
think mrs. the bowtie I think as late as
january early january of 2003 and this i
have at least from from a good friend
who worked with the French Foreign
Office and that Jacques Chirac was still
probing a French participation in a war
against Iraq where he seemed to have
turned was in the degree to which the
Iraqis were cooperating with the
inspectors and his sense that public
opinion in France would not accept the
war unless there were grievance Iraqi
violation which the Iraqis were not
providing at that time and so I don't
buy the financial interests or personal
connection on that I don't think it
holds up against the weight of the
evidence in other areas I think Chirac
overplayed his hand on the war and took
a more forward position than many even
among his advisor suggested
but I think he represented a fairly
strongly held sentiment of the majority
of the French people against the war in
Iraq the branch of the British for that
matter before World War two ever have
any success in the Levant Mesopotamia
any of those areas Transjordan that they
controlled they ever have any success in
democracies in any Arab country or were
they popular at all during that period
they I think it's a it's a very
interesting question of course in a way
by making the point that I did I blurred
over the fact that certainly the French
and British were not really interested
in democratizing of course there could
be a question whether we're really how
strongly were interested in
democratizing as opposed to a stable we
want a stable regime in that region I I
think some of the people in the
administration want a democratic outcome
but I think they'd also be happy for a
fairly stable autocrat as well that
wasn't bizarrely murderous in the case
of the French and British in the Levant
in the interwar years they basically
were these were additions to their
colonial empires they had some success
culturally French culture was actually
fairly significant had fairly
significant impact especially in Lebanon
where there was a Christian community
there and it's in that cultural area
both the French and British had some
impact but politically they left a mess
the British of course left the mess of
Palestine and and the conflicting
promises they made to the Jews in the
Arabs the French for them for their own
part we're able to carve together a
reasonably coherent Lebanon but it broke
apart fairly readily once religious
passions were renewed so I think for a
lot of reasons they have a fair amount
of pessimism about the prospect of
making the state's work in the fashion
in which the United States does
Americans I think if there are sort of
general historical differences we tend
to be more
optimistic historically and then
bitterly disappointed when it doesn't
live up to that optimism the French and
to some extent the British and Germans
all tend to have a slightly less
elevated sense of what's possible we may
end up having to adjust our views they
may have end up justing theirs but
you're quite correct to I think point to
what is not a very pleasing historical
parallel is there something about war
from this side of the ocean as opposed
to the other side of the ocean that may
trip us up if it hasn't already but
there's something about war scene from
our point of view that concerns me
either it's too easy and pieces and
afterthought is there some way you can
speak to that I do think I do think that
we have of course had the experience
with the exception of the terrorist
attacks to not having fought war on our
own soil and to not have that within any
living memory and I do think that may
have the effect of at least making it
something that does go on somewhere else
and me especially with the high-tech
efficiency of our military lead to a
certain overconfidence of those who
believe in the preemption strategy or in
the idea that we can take care of
threats before they occur that this can
be done relatively low cost and with few
casualties I do think in the build-up to
war very little was said about the
relative length of the occupation that
would be necessary in Iraq that's
something that the world war two
generation was prepared to accept in
large part because of course the wars
against Germany and Japan was so bloody
and so long that the idea of leaving
quickly was not something that most
Americans most Americans could be argued
were willing to stay in those countries
to make a real effort to plant
democratic institutions what I worried
about with this administration is the
notion of a sort of low-cost strategy
that basically wars have no sacrifices
except for the small number of men in
the
military and the military families and
that you could have your tax cuts you
can have all of these things there's no
no element of war that imposes any
burdens on the homefront that I think
was misleading because I do think we are
in Iraq for a considerable amount of
time now we are in the middle east for a
considerable amount of time now we're
going to lose men their men and women we
will lose treasure a great deal of it
and I do think the American people were
not adequately prepared for that there
is this sort of sense that they can't be
convinced to bear the sacrifice of the
longer term military endeavor but I do
think I think the fact that we've not
had war on our soil probably has made us
less or more willing to fight then
countries that have I the case that I
know best in this is not France actually
but Germany where I think the experience
of war has had such a profound effect as
to really yield something like a
pacifist culture much stronger certainly
much stronger than in France exist yes
to to the reasons I think that you are
acting two of the reasons that you were
giving for the French position or that
you were dis proving is it possible that
first of all one of the suppositions
which that you had was that we believe
that four or five one of the reasons for
Francis actions were four or five
million Muslims is it possible that your
for one perhaps minimizing that
population is only the the legal
registered population and to I think you
mentioned something about the economic
reasons yes and I believe you mentioned
something that the trade between Iraq
and France only accounted for you know
perhaps one percent of Francis gross
domestic product which if you're
assuming that they have a
trillion-dollar economy which I guess in
dollar terms of that's probably accurate
that would mean therefore what is that
ten billion dollars and in is there any
possibility that again that you might be
minimizing that because there were
allegations of contravening the Gulf War
up impositions thank you I you both
points are well taken and I have to
admit that at various points I thought
both of the factors were more
significant than I do now my own sense
though of looking at French policymaking
during this time is that on the economic
side two-tenths of one percent as a part
of the value of trade yes it that can be
a in strictly cash terms a significant
amount but I think the key point here is
that if you study the way the French
approach the issue they were actually
fairly willing to go in up to a point in
January I think when they saw the
inspection process what they perceived
it actually working so I think you have
to then posit the idea that they didn't
see that their economic interests were
not important before january and then
became important and I guess my own
argument here would be that I just don't
think that economic interest in that
case we're any more significant than
perhaps even the American economic
interests that would have been in the
Middle East that they don't really sway
political leaders to make such a
fundamental choice as that of whether to
cooperate within within the Alliance of
the United Nations said it wasn't that
significant when it came down to it the
second point about Muslims you're
absolutely right that of course there is
a fairly large undocumented population
within France here again I think though
that the record shows that they have
been willing to make choices that have
involved them in significant conflict in
the Arab world despite the presence of
this community I guess I'd make a couple
of points some of this community also
has actually been despite some reporting
here actually become and I'm not sure we
would talk about Americanization I'm not
sure Franco ization as a word but the
second generation has been actually
fairly influenced by their experience in
France and is not as separated and
therefore as determined or as likely to
be influenced by either
terrorist ideas or Islamic ideas this
was still a problem with Algeria but in
the case of Algeria the French were able
to pretty effectively put an end to a
very significant terrorist campaign in
the mid 90s I still remember actually
quite vividly being there because of my
wife's work in in Paris during the
summers we were there during some of the
subway bombings and that was pretty
pretty scary and they were able through
to pretty effectively stop that I guess
my point would be simply that again I
don't think politically it was the
decisive role for shock shock certainly
benefited by it and his appeal to
Muslims within France according to
public opinion polls and surveys of that
population certainly went up as a result
of his stance on the war but I don't
think it was the key reason for leading
him to that stance we're leading France
to that stance
it has been said that France had 60
billion contracts for oil with sedan is
this true most of the analysis I've read
puts the figure considerably less that
doesn't mean that it wasn't there and
that what French companies weren't
affected but that the numbers were not
as as great it's also clear whatever
those figures were that the Iraqi oil
industry was in such a shape as to make
many of those contracts relatively
worthless so I think it's it and not not
from destruction from the war either I
mean this is pretty clear that problem
part of the decay of the industry from
the sanctions and from other areas had
led to serious problems there so most of
the figures i read don't put it in that
style but there were there were french
companies with oil significant oil
contracts with iraq
I want to thank you for your
presentation and I want to ask you to
tell me again the name of your book but
before you avoid before you do that they
are more concerned about is there any
history of any country going into a very
different kind of continent area
philosophy religion as we are now in
Iraq and getting out in any honorable
way probably the the best example and
for a lot of reasons it's not
necessarily applicable but the best
example that those who supported the war
and I think would argue for it would
give would probably Japan where of
course the United States was very
different and when in as an occupier the
problems with that analogy probably
occurred to many of you Japan was more
homogeneous ethnically there was the
United States had an emperor that it
could rule through it didn't have to
search for the the nefarious leader
there as we are doing now and there were
a lot of reasons that played to our
advantage in Japan but and also the fact
that we had fought a four year war the
Japanese knew they were defeated the
atomic bombs that if nothing else
brought that home and the willingness
none of the Emperor to support
cooperation helped a great deal there
wasn't the type of guerrilla resistance
that many would have expected so that's
probably the best example and you can
see for a number of reasons it may not
be appropriate in fact what the United
States is doing in the Middle East now
is an extraordinarily risky gamble and
this is one reason why I think it's
absolutely essential eventually to bring
back in other countries other regions
and especially the authority of the
United Nations and multilateral
alliances to take some of the harsher
notes of occupation and rule by a single
country off of that endeavor that would
provide a very very valuable legitimacy
and could make the effort a success in a
way that perhaps a single American rule
would not
oh the book is Lyndon Johnson in Europe
in the shadow of Vietnam and it's a it
came out just a couple of months ago so
I'm still one of those authors who feels
like the father of a newborn baby and
you talk about it all the time and you
still think about it all the time but
you get very boring but it's um it's a
it was a an endeavor of more years than
I care to recount and more sacrifices
from my my poor family than I care to
recount but it was a lot of fun and
actually did lead me to rethink and
something that I had originally seen as
something different and to rethink it
and to argue and conceptualize it and
argue presented differently than I had
before thanks to your interesting and
informative presentation and again on
behalf aliens vs. like to wish everyone
a happy bastille day and a good evening
a de la palabra de las bolsas de ville
sweat and Clemens well hey hey Jasper
confetti la bestia 10.com pleasure
Petula moon you'll see of wobbles well
thomas allen schwartz is author of
lyndon johnson and europe it's published
by harvard university press on the web
at hup harvard.edu